Wonderful.
Okay.
Julie Zelenski, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
Good, thank you.
It seems just like a few months ago
we were back in the lab
working in CS107e.
Don't remind me.
Those were the good old days.
That was a great quarter.
How was it online this past quarter?
Well, I think for CS professors,
it was maybe,
we had one of the easier jobs
'cause we already do
a lot of our delivery
remote.
We do have a lot of students watching via video
and time shifted and stuff.
So, and so much of our expertise
is in building tools
and online circumstances it turns out.
So we were able to adapt.
We had an office hour cue.
Let's say that we ran
off of the Web.
Your average Latin professor, I bet
did not find it as easy a transition
to move from their traditional
in classroom way of doing stuff
to this or like the sciences, right,
where you have
all kinds of physical atributes.
So, I think we did a pretty good job
in terms of transition.
Our class was twice as big
as we expected it to be
which I think indicated the students also
... with their ... in terms of
where can I make progress
and work on my degree
in this time of turmoil.
And so we had a lot of people showing up
in CS I think
'cause it felt like a safe place
to make some good progress.
I'm very curious to see
what the trends are going to look like
now that it's transitioning online
and what people's choices
are going to make.
But nothing will ever be able to replace
the incredible mentorship
that you and Pat provided
at least me and my cohort.
Coming into the breadboard
and physically showing us how the wires
I don't think it we'll ever be able
to replace that
no matter how great
we'll make virtual be.
But Julie, I want to go back
about your journey.
One of the most popular
computer science professors
within Stanford.
A renowned teacher.
You love teaching, and at the same time,
you love code.
Back at Next, and then Apple.
Experience with Steve Jobs.
And I want to capture everything
in this talk,
and it's going to be impossible
but we're going to start.
Julie, who are you?
Take me through your journey.
How do you come to be
one of the top teachers and lecturers
at Stanford after an incredible career?
It's a master plan.
I've known since day one.
No. I came to Stanford myself
as an undergrad
from a rural public
California high school.
I think without a lot of exposure
to computers or the field,
or any of it
I was a math undergrad, in fact,
all the way through.
And, I picked up
a little computer science late.
Thought it was really neat,
but it wasn't yet obvious to me
how this was going to lead.
It was just one step after another.
You take one class, you kinda like it.
You take another one.
You think it's a fluke.
I do pretty well in
that. I liked it a lot,
but I'm sure it gets a lot harder.
But you keep making the progress.
I ended up at Next.
Next was just getting started
when I was an undergrad.
And so, at that point
they were still in the education only market.
So, there was a lot of attention
at the university level.
And so I worked with
an actual Next employee
who would come to Stanford
to teach this class, right,
on how the Next was programmed
which I thought was super interesting
and it just totally caught my fancy.
Like the
... at that point
was relatively new.
And when you saw the way it enabled
certain kinds of problems to get solved like that,
it's so freaking cool.
Ok Julie, I want to talk about that.
Why is it so freaking cool
when the software is written well?
Yeah. 'cause, I mean, like,
when you start to write code,
you realize there are parts of it
that are kind of tedious, right.
Like, oh, you're running
the same kind of code again and again.
The idea that figuring out ways
to capture that idiom,
that commonality and unify it,
and debug it, and put it in a library,
and reuse it again,
is just such a huge leverage point
for which you can then go on to build
and solve more interesting problems.
So, running a link list.
Sure. Everybody needs to learn this
as part of their etude
of computer science,
but in the end,
what you really want to be doing
is solving these problems.
And you're like,
Oh, I want to be looking at this data
and teasing out these trends
and figuring out what to do with this.
Or, it's like,
Okay, I don't need to solve
these problems anymore
about a hash table
Well, a hash table
it's super awesome and it's wonderful.
But somebody needs to build
a really awesome sorting routine,
a really awesome hash table,
a really awesome graphics ...
a 3D rendering engine.
And then, we all get to build
on top of that.
Like starting on the 10th floor
of our 20 story building
or the 99th floor of our skyscraper.
And so, the idea of figuring out ways,
our tools, and our libraries,
and our systems, can promote reuse, right?
And so we talk about it
early in the sequence.
We're always talking
about the design, and the structure.
I was able to say, Julie, you have
an incredible responsibility
not just as a computer science
faculty member within Stanford,
but you actually teach often
the huge introductory classes as well
like the ... in computer science.
And this is really an introduction
for a lot of students into the breadth
of the complexity behind problem solving
for computer science.
What is that like
to have the responsibility
of having 400 students in an auditorium?
And Julie, one of the first inventors
and instructors they meet?
I mean, computer science is so awesome
because of the fact
that even in that first class
or the second class, right,
you're really in the meat of it.
There isn't this really long
prerequisite chain where you have
to spend a lot of time, sort of
I think, on the background material
before you can get going
and do something interesting.
It's like from day one,
in our CS106A courses,
we're solving little problems. It's like,
Okay. Maybe it's Carol the robot and
it's kind of a little bit of a simplified world,
but you're thinking logically.
You're thinking about repetition,
and if-else logic,
and how you break things down
into ... units.
And it's like, every step along the way
is an opportunity to learn
a little bit more
of good engineering practice.
And so I fell like at the end
of those first two quarters,
you have learned a lot
that's actually very practical
and can immediately you can turn around
and start writing stuff
and building stuff,
and doing stuff with it.
People are going off to work
to do internships at Google and Facebook
after taking these course.
It's just it's so accessible to everyone.
And that's so extraordinary, right?
I mean, I'm not a chemist,
or a biologist, or a physicist,
but I feel like they're these really long chains
before you're able to do something
with, let's say, chemistry,
that where you're really kind of
putting in your practice, right
And CS, it's like such a neat steep ramp
from "I know nothing"
to "I can actually do
some pretty neat things"
in such a short period of time.
That's really an awesome place to be.
So then what is sort of your idea or your vision
and also Stanford's in terms of
how do you get somebody
who comes in and says,
"I want to learn computer science
within this incredible institution, Stanford.
How can you best prepare me
over the next four years
to be the greatest thinker,
problem solver that I can be?"
Because there's a very clear mindset
into this logical sequence that we take
and I'm in it right now and I'm loving it.
I'm so impressed
by how well thought out it is.
Talk to me a little bit about that.
It's totally a team effort, right
I mean, I think, we have a very strong
curriculum design committee
that is in place for the long haul right
And we're constantly looking
at our offerings and there is
One thing that's a little bit different
about Stanford
relative to other R1 institution is that
we do have what we call an Ed Group,
the ED Affairs Group,
and there are like 10 of us.
And that we are teaching only faculty.
And so, the intro sequence CS106,
and 109 and 107, 108, ones like that,
are taught by this group of lecturers
and teaching faculty,
and that means that we give 100%
of our heart and soul to making sure
that that intro sequence
I didn't even know that. That's amazing.
Yeah.
And so, and then as you transition out of intro
and into the upper division.
So you start to hit compilers,
and machine learning,
and graphics and stuff like that.
And so, you'll encounter
the traditional research faculty.
So, someone like Pat.
Pat, and most of us are also people
who are very interested and care
about teaching a lot,
but they're also have an extremely rich
and amazing career as a researcher
which necessarily means
that their attention is going to be split
a little bit more, right,
and they have more attention
placed on mentoring grad students
and whatnot.
So, us being there, right, to make sure
that, for example, we do a ton of teacher mentoring,
we do a bunch of TA training,
we bring our undergraduates
in to work with us in the intro sequence
which gives us a pipeline of people
to step up to be graduate TAs.
Julie, how do you improve? How do you improve on this process?
Because you teach a class of 400 students.
You've just taught it for 10 weeks
and now you have a one week break
and you're about to teach it again.
And as any good computer scientist,
you want to improve and learn
for the next generation.
So, how do you go about doing that?
Well everything I work on,
you can ask anybody who's gone behind me
will tell you, that in the directory
where the files, like the code
or the write up, or the rubric,
or any of the material software,
there's a file on there whose name
is called "For Next Time"
It's in all capitals
It's always named the same thing.
But I put it right there
like it's right by the lecture,
it's right by the section,
it's right by the lab.
And it reminds me of,
as we were doing it,
what was happening.
Was there something that students
got tripped up on it?
Was there something the TAs
told me about it?
Was there something I just felt
coming out of the lecture?
Or if I got a chance
to review the lecture itself, like,
Oh, you know what
that just wasn't that clear
or I need a different example.
And I make those myself.
And I leave 'em right there
'cause it's the one place I'll remember it.
If I put it anywhere else, right,
it's not going to be where I am.
So, at the point when
I'm preparing that lecture up
and start with the last time I had it,
I'll be like, "Oh. Look, what I wrote down"
This example fell flat,
or this needs to be fixed.
We need to fix this explanation whatever.
So, they're littered throughout
everything I work on.
So, it has to be there.
You're right. I mean everything
is so in the moment for teaching.
It's a thousand little to do items
of this week's lecture,
this week's assignment,
this week's lab, that exam, right.
So, that you need a system
to keep each of them.
And then I'd say bigger things.
Like if you're thinking really about
restructuring an entire class,
or really doing something like that
is generally going to be something
that we work on more as a team, right.
Like if there's a much bigger
let's all get together,
let's all brainstorm,
let's all think about whether
Like we recently switched our 106A course,
which has been a JAVA for 10 years,
to Python.
And that was a huge effort
of a lot of people
to survey what other schools are doing.
To look at tools that are out there.
Look at ways it would change
our pedagogy.
Look at the way it's going to affect
other parts of our curriculum.
How long have you been teaching
these monumental classes
within Stanford?
So, I've been here since 1992.
Wow. So, what changed since then?
So you've seen quite a few students go by.
- Yeah
... different than other?
In some ways it feels like
nothing's changed
'cause the core of it,
it's still as beautiful
and as pristine
and heartfelt as it ever was.
Which is, I mean I would say,
one of the things
that's really important about Stanford
is that our intro class
is our intro for everyone.
That we don't have a majors entry point
and a non-majors entry point,
and an advanced student thing like that.
It's like,
Oh there is 106A which is designed
to be called the big tent.
It brings in everybody.
We want everyone to give a chance to it
and be taught in the way we want.
Like to build a foundation
for all computer scientists.
So, some of these are classes
like physics for poets,
or something like that, where it's like,
Oh, you're really not going on,
so we're gonna give you
a different "light" version.
And we really don't want to do that.
We don't want you to have to select
before you've had a chance
to really try it.
And so we want to give you
the same grounding we give everyone.
We really try hard to get people
to start in the intro sequence
even if they have the background
to sometimes jump ahead.
We often think that we can do
such a good job with setting
the right foundation for you
that we want you to give it a try.
That don't be in a hurry to jump ahead
'cause even in the simple exercises
where we can just imbue you
with really good habits that we want you
to carry forward.
So, that's been the same.
So what I want to say
what did we change?
I would say, we've changed the language.
We've changed the tools, right.
Our enrollments have gone crazy large.
But in the essence of it,
I still think we're doing the same thing
we've always wanted to do all along,
which is show you how empowering
and awesome it is to be able to control
this computer and then give you
this really good grounding
in the fundamental sort of tools and technique
and mindset that makes you
be an excellent engineer.
That's so cool.
Julie, what's missing from CS education
at Stanford or anywhere in the world?
Where are we at now?
And what big milestones do you hope
to for us to get to
in let's say, five years?
I think we need to keep looking
at the service part of the equation.
That I think we serve our majors
extraordinarily well.
I think we have a great curriculum
with a lot of flexibility
and in the undergraduate
the master's curriculum, the PhD,
all of that is really really good.
I think we need to keep working at ways
to give computing power to people
who aren't computer scientists
in a way that makes sense for them.
And so, so as I said,
we have this one sequence
and it's for everyone.
And that's great.
And I do think up to a point,
we can definitely keep everybody together,
but there are places where
there's jumping off points where I think
we need to, for example, there are a lot of people
who want to get data science type skills,
machine learning type skills,
but aren't going to make computer science
their number one focus.
And so, maybe they're a biologist
or sociologist, right, or a historian.
And so I think figuring out ways
that we can be sure to coordinate
and support giving those skills to people.
Like the way the writing center,
for example, might be like,
everyone needs to learn
how to write persuasively and attentively.
And so, figuring out how we can be
computer science support
as a service learning for all people.
I'd say, another big area for us
is to dig more deeply
into the ethical implications
of the work we do.
That I think, we've had a little bit
of like, Hey, we're technology.
We're neutral.
We're just teaching you
how algorithms work
and how to evaluate them
for performance
or for robustness or correctness,
but there's really growing awareness
that there are absolutely
certain opportunities for us
to be reflecting on the bias
in the data sets we use
and in the problems
we're trying to solve,
and in the implications of our work
in a broader social context
which I think we need to figure out
how to make that happen up and down
across the curriculum.
I think we've traditionally had an idea
if there's a class or two
that's about ethics or social implications,
and I think we just need
to weave that through our discipline
all the way through
to be sure we're making responsible
ethical choices at every step.
Incredible.
Julie, take me back now to Next
and then Apple.
You're out of Stanford.
You're entering this tech scene.
You get to work with Steve Jobs.
What is this like?
... I get to be with somebody
from the roots of it.
This is incredible.
Yeah. I think it's like,
when I look back at it now,
it seems more amazing that at the time.
I didn't know any better.
It was basically my first job
out of school.
So I thought it was completely normal
that you have a superstar.
Like for the longest time
I had this dingy car,
this Datsun B210
that was an old junker of a car.
And I used to park a little bit far away
from the building
because I thought my car was ugly
and rundown and I was
still just paying off my student loans.
And so, I parked it kinda away
around the corner from the building
kinda a little bit out of shame.
But it was interesting how there was often
a black Porsche that would also be
in this same spot
I picked. It happened to be the first one
around the corner from the building.
And it was a black Porsche
with no license plates, which at the time
I didn't know these stories yet
about how Steve was apparently just
couldn't be bothered
to get a license plate for his car.
And so, depending on who got there first,
either I would have the spot
or the black Porsche would have the spot.
I didn't realize it was Steve's car
until one day I come out,
and he's parked in the next spot over
and he's standing by his car
talking to somebody.
And I'm coming out to my car.
And he scolds me for parking in his spot.
And I'm terrified.
I've been there, I don't know,
not that long
like a few months or something.
But I'm like, I think
I'm about to get fired over
But he was kidding. He didn't care.
It was just funny that everybody else
apparently all knew this.
Don't park in Steve's spot, right.
But I'm like, Oh, okay whatever.
I'm just trying to hide
my ugly car over here.
But anyway, so then
I stopped parking ...
Unbelievable. How many people were at Next
when you joined over there?
So, we were probably close
to 200 people at that point.
I think we've had maybe four or five hundred
at our biggest when were doing
both hardware and software.
But, we did cut our hardware business
and scaled back into softwares.
So the time we got acquired,
we probably were back down
to 200 again.
So, we were pretty small
that whole time, I would say.
What are some
of the most important lessons you learned
from that time that then you took
with you as you then transitioned
back to education?
Yeah. I loved working at Next,
but the strongest memory, of course,
was just the people.
The people who were hired there
and their passion for what we were doing
was just really infectious, right.
And maybe the biggest lesson
I took away from Next was
I had to go back to grad school
because I was working with
So, at that point,
I had an undergrad degree in math.
My training in CS was pretty thin.
I was learning a lot on the job.
I was working at an engineering capacity,
but I was definitely a junior person.
And there were all these people around me
who just had a wealth of knowledge
and experience and practice
that I was super envious of.
And I can remember,
people would casually toss off,
toss off terms or tools or,
Oh, well when I was at Sun
we did this kind of stuff.
And I just wanted,
I was hungry for that same kind of experience,
the same kind of underpinning
of what they knew that helped them
to make great decisions going forward.
And so, it was great to work with them
and learn from them,
but I also knew I needed to go back
to the source myself
and strengthen up my own background.
Were you ... that at the time
you were working with some
of the greatest pioneers of -
Yeah. It seemed normal to me
but that was 'cause
I had never had a real job before.
I mean I was in high school.
I worked in a player piano place.
The idea that I thought
it was super normal to have this
just incredibly high powered,
really dedicated,
really talented group of people
that just solved problems
and batted ideas around.
I can still remember the way it felt like,
since we were so small,
you could make decisions about things.
And it's like you keep looking
for some, like
do we have to get some approval?
I can remember going to ...
who was the head
of the workspace development at the time.
And there was this decision
we needed to make
about how something was going to happen.
So I go to him,
he's relatively new too, right.
So we have this conversation
about what our options are.
We bat some ideas around and then
he says,
"Okay, I think we should do this."
And I'm like, "Well, okay
but that's just you and me.
We're like just two foot soldiers here.
Don't we need to go get somebody else?"
You're looking for your mom.
I don't know what you like.
You'd think we have to have some.
And he's like, "No. No. That's what we do.
This is what we were hired to do,
is make these decisions
and make this stuff happen."
And you're like,
"Oh, I guess we just get to do that."
And that happened again and again.
Just lots of cool things to do
and smart people to work with.
And so, from it I said
I had to go back to grad school
'cause I wanna be able to go
deep on some of this stuff
and school's going to be a good place
for me to do that.
I mean I think there are other people
who learn different ways.
It wasn't the only way maybe to catch up
to that level of expertise.
But for me,
it was I had been a good student
and I think the school worked
for my mindset
and my level of obedience maybe
or something like that.
That is so cool.
Julie, as I go on my journey
and a lot of my friends
going on their journey
into computer science
we're at Stanford in general,
what is the one piece of advice
you would give a young student
as we're about to go and absorb
so many classes
from so many incredible instructors?
What are some things
that I can keep in mind
as I go through this journey
and maintain perspective?
Wow.
I would, there's so many great things
about Stanford, right.
And so many great experiences.
And the one thing I would say is just
be mindful of picking and choosing.
Realizing that saying "yes" to something
often means having to say "no"
to something else and thinking about,
as you look at things,
there's going to be lots of things
that sound really awesome
and are really awesome,
but if they're not right for you,
they're going to eat away
from getting a lot of things
that really matter for you.
So sometimes it's easy to get people
get, I think, a little bit sidelined.
Somebody else is doing this
and that sounds really cool.
Or this seems kind of interesting.
Or I want to take all these classes.
I want to have a double major.
I want to do all this stuff.
And ...
by spreading yourself too thin,
you miss some of the discernment of saying
what are the things
I really want to be sure
I get from Stanford
and I want to make sure
I don't miss out on,
and that really are going to fuel me
for the future.
And then recognize that,
as I say yes to those things,
I want to say yes wholeheartedly
and enthusiastically
and that's gonna give me the strength
to also say no to things
that would otherwise cut into that.
I love it.
I see a lot of students who just seem like
they're just really spread very very thin.
And I feel like that
they get very over-committed.
And then they're dealing with, I think,
a lot of stress and a lot of
I think suboptimal results for that.
I mean, I think that one of the things
that I came in
and was completely blown away
was by the number of opportunities,
and everywhere you turn,
somebody is doing something so cool.
And coming in,
it's like in a playground.
You just want to go on ...
get all the different fruits.
And I think that
one of the hard lessons
that I had to learn,
as well as my friends,
is understanding that,
Okay, well if we really want
to enjoy this time
and make it work for us,
we need to also be able
to devote ourselves
to the projects we commit to.
And it's not gonna do service
to anybody if we just go
and do ... and do five clubs.
So I completely, I take this with me.
You already have that advice
it turns out. I have to give you a different
piece of advice next time, right.
'cause that is a great thing
to have already figured out.
I'm gonna come back for many more advises
along the way.
But Julie, I have to know three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay. I'm going to give you curious
'cause I think that's driven a lot
of what got me everywhere I wanted to be
was just wanting to know,
wanting to see it through.
And then it comes with a heavy dose
of stubborn
'cause I think that
stubbornness and curiosity,
I think, drive all the debugging
in the world, right.
it turns out
I'm gonna figure this out,
and I'm going to know why,
and I'm going to get there.
And then I think what makes me a teacher,
I think, is enthusiasm.
- I love it.
The least I can say, I think,
almost definitively why I'm a teacher
is any time I learn something,
the first thing I'm thinking about
is who am I going to tell that to?
Like I read something in a paper,
or see it online, or go to a talk,
and then I'm like, who else wants to hear
this really cool thing that I learned?
So I think that if you see yourself
as this conduit for information
to come in and flow out,
then teaching maybe the career
you want to look at.
I love it.
Okay, Julie, thank you very very much,
this was inspiring.
I learned so much and I can't wait
to share this with the world.
Thank you for taking the time to do this.
Thank you, Michael. Good to see you.
And thank you for an amazing quarter
of 107e and I can't wait to take more class with you.
It was really inspiring. Really.
Yeah. Yeah.
... that's a whole topic
we could go on for a long time about it
like how phenomenal it is to work
with the people at Stanford.
So, Pat Hanrahan, our co-instructor.
who tas the Turing Award winner.
I just never thought I would spend
my career in the company
of such luminaries nonstop, right.
So, it has been really a great ride.
It was also a very humbling experience
all of a sudden to be exposed to that.
Julie, thank you very very much.
Have a great rest of the day.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you. You too.
Bye bye.